but you are on stage actually and this
is more of a serious thing but actually
I had friends at the Vegas shooting they
were Brian my actually brain into best
friend my husband's best friend he and
his wife were there at the Vegas
shooting when it happened when you were
doing his show and everything and I just
I know you just did a show in Vegas
recently like to kind of I don't know I
guess it was it what was the point of
you doing that because I want right when
that happened and our friends were
literally texting us during the shooting
and we're like what and I terrified me
to ever go on stage and I've been on
stage forever but it just scares you
because you're so vulnerable yeah I mean
it's you know obviously something that I
wouldn't wish on anybody and and it you
know I think for us going back to Vegas
was something that I think we wanted to
do it the right way we didn't want to go
in and try and do it too soon we felt
like there was going to be a lot of
people at our show that probably haven't
been to one of our shows maybe haven't
been to a concert at all since that show
and if they were gonna come back out and
you know that was part of the healing
process for them you know we wanted to
make it a safer environment something
that made them feel safer yeah so we did
Park MGM and and so you know little
5,000 seat arena that you know the other
one was outside 30 40 thousand people
whatever it was and and so this was a
little smaller a little more intimate
where people could come hopefully feel a
little more at ease and hopefully help
some of them I mean we had to kind of
get on stage the next week you know and
start trying to get through all of it so
right off the bat did you talk to anyone
cuz I'm telling you what I you know the
bit the best thing that has been kids
yes saying like it's not just you going
out there you have a family yeah it's I
mean it was it was rough I think the
best thing that could have happened was
the fact not that could have happened
but the best thing for me was the fact
that my wife was there went through it
my band was there and went through it my
crew everybody and so we kind of leaned
on each other you know for that stuff
and talked through it you know nobody
kind of kept it bottled up I mean if you
had a had a breakdown you kind of had it
in front of everybody and everybody knew
what was going on you know my wife you
know we could talk and she understood
you know what was going on because she
was there yeah
so it was just I think to me that
probably helped more than anything but
you know we're on the other side of it
now and and you know we're part of the
root not any one family now so it's a
it's a cool group it is it is it's a
good name I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this